Is there a test to measure toxins in our drinking water?
That's a good question. I actually just talked to somebody about testing for glyphosate in their drinking water, but you can do so.
I, you know, you could you could test for toxins, certain toxins in any water supply, but typically when people are asking to test their water supply, they're asking to test their well water.
No, you could test any water, I suppose, because who knows if you're sitting with a spality is tested for things, right?
But the well water testing that can be done through the county, like we just had our water tested last year. I think it was maybe the year before through the county.
They test for, I think, heavy metals, they test for nitrates, sulfides, things like that.
And that's really the extent that they test for maybe like six different things.
So then you're at, okay, how do I test for other toxins in my water? I don't know. You'd have to Google any labs that test for other toxins. I do know that those it does hasn't have a glyphosate test, so that you can get a water glyphosate test.
So that you can get a water glyphosate test. So many of you through us had your urine tested for glyphosates.
That's how that's your glyphosate count in you. But then you go, let's say it was really high in your question, where like the exposed to glyphosates, then you could test your drinking water.
So was there a lab has a glyphosate test for your water? So I ordered that for a person today. So that is a test that you can run. That was far as tested for other different contaminants and toxins.
I personally don't know of any labs that do that though. I'm sure there may be some out there.
But I never looked at it. So you have to Google it. You want to test for a glyphosate? We've contacted us. It's not that expensive, but it's like $120 or something like that to test for glyphosate urine.
Let's go back to that question. What would you do if you had toxins in your water or if you suspected toxins, let's see, I'm supposed to have toxins in the water. I don't, I just, I know that I do, I don't want to spend the money on the test. I'd rather spend the money on the fix.
Well, typically reverse osmosis would be the way to go to get a reverse osmosis using it in your house. And depending on where you live, you know, typically you can rent those. I don't call a good water as that you can rent.
Echo water is another system that I think is a little bit better than the elegant water system, but I don't know if they rent those.
So you can contact water software type company many times. They will have reverse osmosis units. They will come and install them.
I do do know you can buy a reverse osmosis unit in a big box store like a large or a little deeper or something like that, but I don't recommend that there's far inferior.
I would get to call a good water, the echo water one.
I think at this office, we rent the call again, what I think it's like 30 bucks a month.
So that's something to look into.